sur les quais le crustacé ne se fait pas
attendre
on débarque en charge puis on le prépare
pour expédition direction les états unis
l'europe l'asie du sud s est de plus en
plus la chine surtout selon cet
exportateur de produits de la mer depuis
l'imposition de tarifs par la chine de
25% sur le homard américains en juillet
dans les deux dernières années on a on a
doublé notre chiffre d'affaires sur la
chaîne pôle phare a profité tellement de
cette guerre commerciale qu'il a dû
investir dans ses moyens de production
pas ce qui nous a poussés à aller
chercher des usines sur l'atlantique
interne d'un ordre nouveau brunswick
même sur les états unis pour pouvoir
répondre aux demandes grandissant de nos
clients il n'est pas le seul
si toutes les industries canadiennes qui
en tire avantage en moins d'un an les
exportations de homard canadien vers la
chine ont augmenté en moyenne de 135 %
si le marché canadien profite du
contexte actuel et son nom peu à croire
qu'il faut rester vigilant et ne pas
mettre tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier
sans oublier que les relations
commerciales du canada avec la chine
sont déjà tendues depuis l'arrestation
de la directrice financière de wei wang
yong jo paul farah on est bien conscient
toute entreprise qui gère bien sa
distribution et son plan marketing à
long terme doit avoir plus d'un marché
de plus la plupart des gros joueurs de
l'industrie canadienne ou des
investissements états unis et vice versa
[Musique]
mais pour le fara se méfie de l'appétit
des chinois pour le homard et il faut
aussi être vigilant et proactif au
niveau de la législation au canada pour
protéger nos producteurs
nous producteurs canadiens à nos
exportateurs canadiens nos pêcheurs
canadiens pour ne pas se faire devancer
dans des investissements étrangers qui
proviennent de la chine qui peuvent
peut-être paraître alléchante au
demeurant mais sur le long terme ça peut
avoir une conséquence très négatives sur
notre source
déjà dans les dernières années des
usines de transformation sont passés aux
mains de chinois une façon de tenter de
contrôler la ressource et le prix des
précautions sont donc de mise pour
préserver une richesse locale tout en
profitant pleinement de ses fruits ici
elisa céret radio-canada diète